and parents in less than a month clark
county school district students heading
back to class it goes fast
health officials also urging families
take care of
necessary vaccinations ahead of time
kate houston stopped by a clinic down in
the southwest valley which is also
offering covet covid19 vaccines to
families
as families head out to get back to
school supplies health officials are
also urging them to take care of back to
school vaccinations
pediatricians say it's okay to get
mandatory shots with the kovid 19
vaccine
at the same time the most important
thing is for her to get the vaccine
over the next few weeks families will be
checking off their to do lists which
include various mandatory shots for
students in kindergarten and seventh
grade as well as the covid19 vaccine
offered to kids 12 and older
this is very convenient and super fast
van lee stopped by fez middle school in
the southwest valley to get his daughter
melanie vaccinated against kovid 19
before she starts high school this fall
i was just
tired of not being able to be in super
close proximity with my friends
and i wanted to be able to move on
and like really focus on my studies not
to worry about anything else
fess is one of many schools offering
vaccinations through the southern nevada
health district
sometimes it becomes a family event even
here in our office we'll give the
child and their parents a vaccine at the
same time dr michael tenby with
centennial pediatrics
says although the time frame has passed
for students to be fully immunized
against covet 19 before school starts
getting the shot now can still offer
some protection
and keep them in class they may be sore
for a day or two
they may not feel great for the next day
yet another reason you may want to start
the series before they
go back to school so they miss less days
of school kate houston 8 news now